basándonos en lo que vimos en el vídeo
pasado vamos a ver si le podemos poner
nombre a estas dos moléculas empezando
con esta lo primero que vemos es que
tiene un doble enlace entonces ya
sabemos que es un al que no y que va a
tener la terminación en no entonces lo
escribimos de una vez por acá por otro
lado se ve aquí cuál es la cadena de
carbonos más larga que tiene 1 2 3 4 5 6
7 carbonos así es que estamos lidiando
con un
con un obsceno y para saber cuál es el
número que tenemos que poner por aquí y
el doble enlace está más cerca de este
extremo entonces este es el carbono 12
4 5 6 7 y el doble enlace está en el
tercer carbono entonces usted es un ept
3 en o sea a esta molécula le faltaba un
hidrógeno por aquí bueno pero además
tiene un grupo metilo en el cuarto
carbono así es que es un cuatro metil
f-314 metil eps 3 heno y bueno este
nombre está muy bien para esta molécula
pero como vimos en el vídeo pasado
todavía tenemos que especificar más
acerca de esta molécula porque tiene
otras con formaciones a las cuales no es
equivalente aunque y para hacer eso
utilizamos el sistema de nomenclatura
antich en su semen y lo que hacemos es
poner una seta de sus amén de juntos en
alemán si los grupos funcionales de
mayor prioridad de cada uno de estos dos
carbonos están juntos en el mismo lado
o sea se están los dos arriba o los dos
abajo y poner una de antich en d en
oposición en alemán si están en dos
lados distintos uno a uno arriba y otro
abajo ahora porque gira todo alrededor
del doble enlace pues porque los dobles
enlaces son los que no pueden rotar y
los que hacen que las distintas
conformaciones no sean equivalentes
entonces lo que tenemos que hacer aquí
es ver cuál es el grupo funcional de
mayor prioridad de cada uno de estos dos
carbonos de este lado es muy fácil
porque aquí tenemos un hidrógeno y un
grupo funcional etilo y el grupo
funcional etilo tiene mayor prioridad
que un hidrógeno ahora este carbono es
más complicado porque aquí tenemos dos
grupos funcionales tenemos el grupo
metilo que ya mencionamos y esta otra
parte de la cadena podemos pensar que es
un grupo pro pilot y tenemos que
determinar cuál de estos dos grupos
tiene mayor prioridad
para hacer eso utilizamos el esquema de
prioridades de can in gold pre gold que
vimos hace algunos vídeos pero bueno
básicamente lo que dice es tomas el
carbono del cual estás buscando cuál es
el grupo funcional de mayor prioridad y
te fijas a qué átomo está enlazado y el
grupo que tenga en ese átomo el mayor
número atómico ese es el grupo de mayor
prioridad ahora en este caso a ambos
grupos funcionales empiezan con un
carbono entonces el número atómico es el
mismo y entonces lo que se hace es ver
cuál es el siguiente átomo de la cadena
en este caso este carbono está enlazado
con tres hidrógenos entonces el
siguiente átomo es un hidrógeno pero en
este grupo funcional este carbono está
enlazado con dos hidrógenos y con un
carbono y el carbono tiene un mayor
número atómico que el hidrógeno entonces
este grupo funcional tiene mayor
prioridad y entonces cuando tratamos de
decidir si esta molécula es
impliquen o sus amén nos fijamos en los
dos grupos estos dos grupos de mayor
prioridad de cada uno de estos dos
carbonos y nos fijamos en si están en el
mismo lado o no estos dos grupos si
están en el mismo lado porque están los
dos arriba entonces están juntos o sea
que están sus amén y ponemos por aquí
entre paréntesis una zeta
así es que esta molécula es z4 metil f 3
1 ahora vamos a escribir el nombre de
esta otra molécula empezamos notando que
tiene un doble enlace por lo cual es un
al que no iba a terminar con el no y que
este enlace doble está más cerca de este
extremo de esta cadena de carbonos
entonces vamos a empezar a numerarlos
por aquí este es uno 2
y 4 5 6 7 8 así es entonces tiene 8
carbonos y el doble enlace empieza en el
tercer carbono así es que tenemos un ok
no
además esta molécula tiene este grupo
funcional de bromo en el tercer carbono
entonces tenemos que agregar por aquí 3
bromo y bueno ahora sí vamos a ponernos
a ver cuál es el grupo funcional de
mayor prioridad de este carbono y bueno
aquí nada más tenemos un hidrógeno o sea
que tenemos un solo grupo funcional así
es que ese es el de mayor prioridad pero
de este lado ya tenemos dos grupos
funcionales y bueno como esta cadena es
más larga tú te puedes sentir muy
tentado a decir que este es el grupo
funcional de mayor prioridad de este
carbono sin embargo eso no es cierto
porque recuerda que en el sistema de
kant ingold prelog el grupo funcional de
mayor prioridad es aquel cuyo primer
átomo tiene un mayor número atómico y el
número atómico del bromo es 35 mientras
que el número atómico del carbono es
simplemente 6 así es que este es el
grupo de mayor prioridad y ahora si
tenemos toda la información como para
decidir si ésta es una molécula xuxa
o impliquen y bueno aquí podemos ver que
los grupos funcionales de mayor
prioridad de cada uno de estos carbonos
del doble enlace están del otro lado o
sea no están juntos están en oposición a
si es que están en quequén ok porque
están separados uno está arriba y el
otro está abajo
esta es de expliquen en qué bien qué
significa en oposición y está z es de su
semen su sal
men de juntos en alemán